in one of the more desperate attempts to  kill scp-682 the hard to destroy reptile  the scp foundation employed the use of  scp-3802  a bottle of anti-baldness ointment known  as hair growth by datto but not just any  hair if you apply this to the skin of an  adult they'll break out in huge painful  tumorous masses that turn into giant  flemish rabbits this anomalous chemical  was spritzed onto scp-682 by the  sprinklers causing the beast horrific  pain and massive unchecked tumor growth  as these tumors broke away and became  giant rabbits they tore off 40 of  scp-682's body mass however it didn't  stick as scp-682 ate the rabbits while  it was regenerating back to the drawing  board